foreign
[Music]
I ain't anymore
what kind of brush you got only the guy
that'll get you chased down no matter
where you go
so where is it I lost it the only way
for you to get me paid is the
old-fashioned way Autumn fact
you might get hurt if you do
get hurt if you don't
[Music]
just take it I don't want it it's the
type of money that could change
somebody's life
son of a gun the butcher standing right
here in front of me after all these
years you so fine
the lady at the store said you were a
fighter that right once upon a time why
do you have to fight tonight long story
you ain't no good to me dead but you
gonna give me a fight you in a big hole
that got bigger when you started dancing
around big moments
there is this great big world out there
and sometimes it spins against you
but sometimes it's binging right into
what you need
I can't tell you what you want to hear
it's took me yeah
but hell
has caught up
[Applause]
battle come on
you don't look capable no more capable
of what
[Music]